like as somebody who
his job it is to like know what's going
on and like talk about the leaks and
everything
i didn't know this
i i really didn't um and i am going to
talk about post-credit scenes don't
worry obviously not giving anything away
but
there are two
we will uh we'll talk about them
what's up everybody it's warren and i
just attended the red carpet world
premiere of xiangxi and the legend of
the 10 rings this is something that is
just it's truly an amazing experience
for me something i've wanted since i was
a little kid and started loving movies
and this is only possible thanks to you
all supporting me and supporting the
channel so right away thank you so much
for all the support that you all have
given me this is going to be a spoiler
free review about chongqi i've calmed
down a little bit from the whole event
so i'm going to try to really give you a
constructive uh non-spoiler review i i
will say i did love the movie um
it's what i wanted from the movie and
again a little bit more too um
i i really was concerned right away
that it was going to be more
marvel-esque
and not so much kung fu but it actually
had
a lot of kung fu in it like
the fighting was crazy cool
and i went with my buddies greg galba
john humphrey and greg's fiance olivia
over at the real rejects who i'm sure
most of you guys know about if you don't
goes up to them they're awesome
they were super cool to me they picked
me up from the airport greg did
and we all walked away thinking that the
movie was pretty dang good uh john
campio was sitting right next to me
and when the movie was over he came over
to me greg and johnny was like is it
just me was that movie effing great and
that was like i freaking loved it
i loved it it has a very black
panther-esque feel to it as in it's
something different than what marvel has
done before
in a very very good way
the cinematography
of this movie is fantastic it's a
beautiful movie uh i i remember thinking
a few times like this movie is beautiful
it's visually so satisfying so pleasing
it's it's pretty incredible it it's
really insane
the story is good i was worried about
the story as well it's fantastic i like
how they did it they did a lot of
flashbacks but they did them really
really well not like you know something
could be done poorly they did them
really really well um the characters
i say have good
motivating factors be behind them
you know the villain and there is
at the end there's something that's like
really really
just
unexpected
um
i do like as somebody who
job it is to like know what's going on
and like talk about the leaks and
everything
i didn't know this
i i really didn't um and i am gonna talk
about post credit scenes don't worry
obviously not giving anything away but
there are two
we will uh we'll talk about them
um
the this movie
i feel really
it connected to the bigger marvel
universe
without making it about that right like
the whole movie is not about like the
marvel universe it's about chiang chi
and his world his sister his father his
mother
his people
and they did really good like they did a
really good job at like tying in little
things
to the main marvel universe i mean
obviously you've seen the trailers
abomination wong um
and they don't take focus away from that
like they don't take focus away from
that so it's like super super cool um
yeah
the movie was great really um the only
like little qualm that i have with it is
at the end
i feel like the story arc of win will
change dad could have
they could have put more to it
again no spoilers but i feel like if you
get like we had just like five more
minutes it would have been so much
better
um
and that's really all i got as far as
what i i didn't necessarily like about
it i think i liked every scene in the
film again visually it's really cool the
kung fu is really really great the
choreographer for everything is really
great there are times like greg alba
said
i didn't know
if it's cgi or martial arts like i
legitimately didn't know which was
kind of weird because
like
usually you can tell but it's so well
done and there are some parts
where
the cgi is a little less than in other
parts which usually happens in movies
they save like you know the big budget
cgi moments for like certain moments and
you can definitely tell when those
moments are in this movie they look very
well but there are some like minor parts
where it's like the bus scene that we've
seen in the trailer so i'll talk about
it right where shaun chi is fighting
he's fighting razor fist and a few other
guys like there's a part where like the
bus is kind of going down
uh the road
and it's not so good it's like okay i
could like this is a cgi bus right it
doesn't look entirely real but i mean we
know it's not really happening so who
cares but the cgi is really good
in like the final scene right uh the
final moments the ancient city
is like
super cool um
they did it really really well the
costumes were done insanely well it was
so bright
and and colorful
and again i can't really express how
visually cool this movie was
um it's a good combo like cgi and
realness
i really enjoyed it
so there are two
post credit scenes there's a mid credit
and a post credit and the mid credit is
so cool um i obviously cannot say
what it is this is a spoiler free review
and of course marvel at disney asked you
not to reveal anything
but it's important
and it's cool i don't think anybody can
see the mid-credits scene and not be
like oh
my god
uh
it's cool and the post credit scene the
one after the credits is done uh
i would say is a little
little
less important and crazy cool
um
than the mid credit scene but still
sets things up
yeah
um
but the mid credits scene is pretty cool
and i'm really excited for people to see
it so two post credits scene one after
you know what we call the mid credits
and then one after everything is finally
done uh everyone's gonna really enjoy it
i hope everybody really enjoys the movie
i mean it's pretty incredible
um now at first the movie ended i was
like i love this movie it's one of my
favorite marvel movies ever might quite
possibly be my favorite movie
uh from marvel period um i tried to calm
down since then but it's still one of my
favorite marvel movies ever now like
ever it's one of my favorite marvel
movies and typically when i like try to
rank things i don't throw like infinity
war end game in there because they're so
big
and unless another movie is going to
just be so big like that and throwing so
many different characters in that you
can't really compare them so
right now thor ragnarok is my favorite
movie um but this movie
gives it a run for its money it really
does because it's very different from
what marvel has done but it still is
marvel it's not so different that you're
like that wasn't a marvel movie it most
certainly is
but the way he uses the ten rings the
fight scenes with the tin rings are so
cool the way that they're used
is really really cool like the last
hour how 45 minutes of the movie is so
cool
the way everything happens
that i just i don't see how people are
gonna go watch this movie and think it's
bad i just i can't see that
i'm of course there will be people
obviously because that's just you know
you like what you like i never tell you
know i never try to force an opinion on
anybody
whether i like something or don't like
something you like what you like but i
think it's going to be really hard for
people to like say like saying shang shi
sucked i don't think that's going to
happen um
and if you see it when it comes out you
think it sucks uh please tell me like
tell me why you think it sucked because
uh seriously i can find like just one
maybe two things
about like just character arc climaxes
and really those are like my only qualms
is with win woo besides that like every
scene was really cool it had comedy in
it of course aquafina is fantastic sima
liu
blew it away the casting was perfect
like they all did what they were
supposed to do the characters were
fantastic
um i it's hard for me to find things
wrong with this and i'm i'm looking now
that it's over right i'm trying to recap
in my head and i do get to see it again
tomorrow night um back in not in l.a
right here i'm in the hotel right now as
you can still see i still have my uh
where's the camera shang chi
guest pass
on here and they gave us a
shank
bag to take home which is pretty cool
it's got a funko pop in here
and
a soda
with the
simu on it which is pretty cool
overall it's just like a really really
cool event for me it is a really cool
thing to walk the red carpet and see a
bunch of other people
that
are in the industry other youtubers
other people from major you know
websites and stuff like that it was just
all really cool but
the biggest thing i was hoping for
is that the movie was good and i can
honestly say it's top three for sure
now in my favorite marvel movies top
three i'm not sure if it beats ragnarok
because they are two very different
movies and thor is my favorite character
but
it's close now um
definitely in top three it's probably
probably my second favorite marvel movie
now um
yeah i mean again without really giving
any spoilers away which i'm not allowed
to yet this isn't you know
uh you know a big review this is kind of
my reaction um once the movie is finally
out for everybody i'll i'll do a review
about it
but my initial reaction to this movie is
fantastic and i hope that everybody
i hope it's as fantastic to everybody as
it is to me as well because i
i truly enjoyed it i truly enjoyed it i
think they did
a lot right with it um
but you guys finally see it
let me know i'll probably be talking a
lot about it
um until it comes out we only we don't
have that much longer until it comes out
uh but please go see it when it comes
out and let me know what you think about
it because again i
it's fantastic i'm a big fan of simileo
um
i love kim's convenience it's one of my
favorite shows on netflix if you haven't
watched it it's pretty funny um and he
he's in that he does a really really
great job in that and i'm so glad that
he gets you know his own movie now
because he did fantastic the martial
arts is incredible um
the story is great
comedy is fantastic it's it's really all
pretty dang good so
please go see it and when you see it
let's talk about it um and again i just
want to say thank you to everybody for
supporting me
to get to here i hope we only continue
to go up as a community i hope uh to
keep making good videos for you guys and
until the next one wolf wolf